you may think of glaciers as slow-moving
behemoths grinding their way centimeters
at a time but some glaciers can suddenly
shift gears flowing many metres per hour
before slowing down often for weeks or
months and such surges appear to be on
the rise a glacier is said to be surging
when it flows at least 10 times faster
than its usual pace many surges are too
slow for the naked eye to perceive but
time lapses of glaciers reveal their
movements thousands of glaciers are
perched near human settlements and
dozens of searches over the past few
decades have claimed lives not only do
surges pose a threat to nearby
settlements but they can block rivers
create lakes that later unleash floods
and threaten the flow of meltwater that
towns and farms downstream depend on
until recently researchers believe that
it glaciers physical characteristics and
properties of the local terrain
determined surge potential but now they
believe another factor plays a major
role thermal balance pooling on the
surface during the melt season water can
infiltrate a glacier through crevices
and ultimately reach the base warming
lubricating and finally releasing the
ice
[Music]
neighboring glaciers in western Tibet
experienced back-to-back surges in 2016
killing nine people computer modeling
suggested that increased precipitation
and warming boosted the amount of
meltwater by 50 percent before the
surges with more water to seep through
the cracks and eat the ice away the
glacier tongues finally became unmoored
resulting in the surges to stay out of
trouble glaciers need to keep in balance
researchers have observed that glaciers
more easily maintain thermal balance in
cold dry climates where they can shed
heat to the frigid air and warm humid
environments where they can discharge
heat in steady streams of meltwater
models predict that glaciers that don't
meet these conditions are more prone to
search
[Music]
sure enough surging glacier hot spots
are in temperate latitude mountains such
as Karakoram and at lower altitudes like
Svalbard if thermal balance is an
important trigger for surge then climate
change will have an impact recent
findings suggest that a warming world
may be boosting the number of surges in
some regions in Karakoram from 1990 to
2004 two times the number of surges
occurred than in the previous 14 years
analysis of searches of the Lowell
glacier from 1948 to 2009 showed the
time between surges has shortened from
20 years to 12 years scientists hope
that by continuing to track and model
surges they can figure out why glaciers
move at such wildly different rates if
their findings yield insights into the
dynamics behind search perhaps they can
better anticipate sea-level changes and
ultimately save lives
you